chad program are you still there with us
yes i'm here dana so thank you
what was the final there pretty much
what we thought the fade accompli
5149 the senate voted to reject the
motion on calling witnesses and because
they don't know
the road map next this is why the senate
is now in a recess of an undetermined
period they're going to go off stage and
try to figure out what's next but 51-49
that was the breakdown
and that's kind of what we thought
earlier today once we got the
announcement from lisa murkowski that
she would oppose calling witnesses
and the announcements last night from
lamar alexander mitt romney susan
collins and so on everything was set in
stone
but again the problem is mitch mcconnell
doesn't know how to get to a final vote
that's what the
uh in the senate trial and that's what
these offstage negotiations
are going to be about deep into the
night tonight dana all right chad we
have one question from juan and then
we're going to get some commentary from
greg and emily go ahead one so you get
two votes
from republicans chad for allowing the
witnesses
and now you're telling us that in fact
it's the republican side led by mitch
mcconnell that doesn't have the votes
to shut this down uh and i think
uh just sitting here that it must be
that repub some republican senators want
the opportunity to speak
as to why they are voting the way they
are voting when it is seen as so
damaging to the institution absolutely
you could see where someone like susan
collins the republican from maine
she is facing a competitive re-election
fight this fall
in a battleground state uh she might
want to come out
and talk about her position you know
there's a lot of senators even though
those who want to extinguish this trial
as quickly as possible
who say we are senators this is an
impeachment trial
we have not been given the opportunity
to deliberate
and speak on the senate floor it is our
right i mean that's the fundamental
right of the senate there's unlimited
debate
and if you're going to neuter that you
fundamentally change the essence of the
senate and if you've had none of that in
a senate trial
some people might think that that
undercuts the quintessence of the senate
launch we have chuck schumer now live
chad thank you so much let's go to chuck
schumer
responsibilities where the senate turned
away from truth
and went along with a sham trial
this if the president is acquitted with
no witnesses
no documents the acquittal will have no
value
because americans will know that this
trial
was not a real trial it had no witnesses
no documents
it is a tragedy on a very large scale
i will be now going up to my caucus to
discuss what we're doing next i will not
talk about it here
okay thanks all right
um chad pergram um if you're still there
if
basically chuck schumer knew that this
was the likely outcome
um what now is he going to go up and
talk to his caucus about
well he's kind of reveling in the fact
that mitch mcconnell has this problem
the problem is not with democrats the
problem is with republicans you know
they have the majority if you have the
majority
move and so that's the issue right now
uh and so he's going to talk to his
caucus about if they come back into
session
what things does he put on the table
what proposals you might remember that
very lengthy session
tuesday night last week going into the
wee hours of wednesday
where they considered multiple proposals
from from schumer
about how to consider this trial what
witnesses to call talking about calling
john bolton
talking about calling mick mulvaney the
acting white house chief of staff
you could have a similar uh you know
reprise of that in the next few hours if
the senate were to be in session
and this is why mcconnell has recessed
the senate so they don't get
into that right away and then you have a
lot of senators some of those vulnerable
centers having to take those challenging
votes
or dragging the senate down into this
quagmire over the next few hours as they
fight over this
what they try to do is he's going to go
back and say okay what are the issues
here what should we be considering you
know there was a proposal
from dick durbin the democratic whip
along with sharon brown from ohio and
richard blumenthal of connecticut
to allow all senators to have a
10-minute wedge of time
to talk you know put their positions on
the record about the trial again because
senators have not spoken
on the senate floor during this lengthy
trial and so you know senators think you
know they represent
x number of people in each state they
should at least be able to express their
views
on the senate floor in a debate in only
the third presidential impeachment trial
in senate history some people regardless
of whether you think you should impeach
the president united states or not say
if you don't do that
then what good is the senate at all if
you can't even debate that on the senate
floor
chad that makes a lot of sense i can i
can understand why the senators want to
have their say thank you so much let's
go to john roberts
with the latest for us uh wherever you
are john
north lawn of the white house foreign
love to be down there with you in miami
where the president is winging his way
to ward or at least most of the way
there he'll be
landing in west palm beach uh pretty
soon i'm sure that they were watching
the vote
on air force one a short time ago
clearly it was no surprise they knew
that mick mulva made he
had the votes to turn down witnesses and
it's interesting because the president
has said all along hey look i'd like to
have witnesses i'd like to hear from
john bolton i'd like mick mulvaney to to
testify i'd like to
have mike pompeo go up there and tell
his story but i also
want to hear from people like hunter
biden and the whistleblower and maybe
even joe biden i mean it was clear
that if there were going to be witnesses
that the republicans and the president
in particular
were going to push for democrats can't
just have their witnesses the white
house and the president
are going to want to have his witnesses
as well
so i mean this this does alleviate a
long
and protracted battle because i'm sure
that there's no way that pat cipolloni
was going to let john bolton get up
there in front of congress
and testify without it going through all
of the courts
and that could be a lengthy process that
could take place over the course of
weeks if not
months so this is going to alleviate a
long drawn-out battle it could go well
into the democratic
primary contest but i think what we're
seeing here
uh in the senate is a no surprise to the
white house
i think they're probably pretty happy
with the outcome but as chad pergram was
saying
now how do you get to the end the white
house is confident
that there are not 67 votes to take the
president out
uh there might be a couple of uh
republican defections but that only is
going to get you
to maybe 50 50 one votes maximum so
certainly not the 67. so president trump
uh is confident that he's not going to
be removed from office and you and you
watch because
he tweeted about it again today saying
that he believed that the process in the
house
was completely unfair the democrats had
all the witnesses they wanted a lot of
it was behind closed doors some of the
transcripts of those closed door
sessions
were not released his team was not
allowed any witnesses in the house
proceeding
didn't even have a chance to present its
case until it got to the senate and and
that's something that he will definitely
focus in on between now and november
uh and to say that you know republicans
are not getting a fair shake out of this
process
and that nothing like this should ever
happen to another american president the
president
will say dana that he's doing this for
future presidents not just himself
he has said that john thank you we have
news from chad program about something
out of mitch mcconnell's office chad
yes so mitch mcconnell just put out a
statement about that vote that went down
rejecting witnesses he said look we've
been through all of these documents
we've heard all these arguments we don't
think that we need to have witnesses but
i'm going to refer to the final
paragraph of this statement here from
mitch mcconnell here and i'm just
reading this off my phone because things
are happening in real time here on
capitol hill
senators would now confer among
ourselves with the house managers and
with the president's council to
determine the next steps
as we prepare to conclude the trial in
the coming days
in the coming days this is the first
time definitively we've heard something
from someone in leadership
the you know the senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell indicating that this is
not going to wrap up
eminently i was told earlier in the day
that they thought that there was no
chance that they would finish this
tonight
so coming days is the key question now
again you know a couple of hours ago
on another program i was asked whether
or not they would consider
postponing state of the union there's a
bit of a logistical
issue here for tuesday i spoke to one
congressional security source who told
me
that there had been no consideration of
that whatsoever uh but would not rule it
out
you know here's the other thing that so
much of what we see in politics
is very scripted it's very you know kind
of wrote we expect
a and b then c what we're seeing here at
the capitol tonight
is unfolding in real time we really
don't know how this is going to turn out
we know that probably in a day or two
that they will exonerate the president
of the united states
on the articles of impeachment but what
happens in the interim what happens
tonight
what happens over the weekend who gets
to speak you know that interim uh
you know kind of process is very up in
the air and mitch mcconnell nor chuck
schumer nor any of us
can interpret exactly what's going to
happen because nobody really knows
why it will come down to the votes they
have to figure out some sort of
agreement 51 votes that can pass the
senate to set the remaining framework
for this trial
and get to final verdicts for the
president as mitch mcconnell says
in the coming days close quote all right
yeah all right close quote thank you
chad
program we're going to take it around
the table here while in the remaining
time that we have
you have some thoughts there great thank
god he kept that short
wow look i've said the same thing over
and over again because we knew what was
going to happen
the story never changes it's like when
you're dealing with a drug addict who
says no no i've changed i swear i've
changed
no this story has been the same we knew
how the vote was going to go we know how
it's going to go
next week or the week after that because
we know the colonel
the nugget of this story is that it was
initiated three
years ago right this quixotic adventure
is not about a phone call
it was about the day hillary lost so we
all know that what we're being forced to
participate in
is the democrats version of revenge porn
and that's why
it is so exhausting to be sitting here
and listen every day to this
and then have to feel bad for the viewer
who has to sit through this crap
well it's funny that you mentioned that
because adam schiff actually tried to
get naked pictures of donald trump
so well said greg i'm not going to spike
the football juan
because i don't want to do that i'm not
a showboat those democrats just suffered
an
enormous tactical loss right then on the
floor of the senate
we know how it ends from now this is a
strategic
retreat by the democrats they're still
trying to empty their clips
but it's pretty much done mcconnell has
guided this thing
through the system very well very
methodically
very maturely a little bit of a speed
bump here but i'm sure he's going to
kind of bring the boat to home now
this now looks more than ever like this
whole impeachment thing
was a move to protect joe biden trump
had zeroed in on his
family's corruption they tried to knock
him out at the knees
it went all the way up to the senate
trial and then we get an acquittal
and you have to look at yourself and
think this thing backfired because now
everybody's talking about where's hunter
everybody understands joe quid pro
joe is his new nickname not sleepy
anymore his crowd size
is microscopic at this point and bernie
sanders is surging in iowa
so it did not go as planned and my only
thing now is
what do the democrats do next you know
they boycotted the inauguration
they teed up a special counsel
investigation they tried to impeach the
president
he gets acquitted what are they going to
do in a second term
i mean they handled the first loss so
terribly what happens with the landslide
i'm just i'm scared juan hold me okay
i think it's gonna be dangerous i know i
know i know my darling you are so
i'm a snowball because i can see
that on the republican side right now
mitch mcconnell's scorched earth
strategy to protect the president
clearly
it's no longer the gop it's the party of
trump and they are protecting trump
at all no holds barred let's just
protect donald trump
they couldn't get two republicans right
now to say shut down a fair trial no
witnesses
so that's why the two broke away they
could but remember
the american people and democrats
couldn't get four to simply say let's
have a fair trial let's have some
witnesses you're gonna get three
senators democrats
hang on hang on so what you get right
now
is republicans republican senators
starting to ask questions about how they
come out of this even in the party of
trump
what will they look like with a ticket
led by donald trump where they have to
defend the fact
that they allowed the senate the
institution to suffer such
damage that they allowed the american
people
to be deluded that john bolton is off
the charts
everybody around donald trump goes down
and they say oh but we got to protect
donald trump
emily people have such strong feelings
on both sides and if you look at the
polling from the beginning of this to
now
nothing has changed except for the
president's approval ratings
ticked up a point or two right because
while this is all going on he's actually
earning the paycheck that he donates
whereas everyone else on the hill
they are not earning the paychecks that
we pay and that our tax
tax dollars pay i i think we're so far
beyond strategy at this point we're so
far beyond tactics
it's just ego the ego of the ego of
schumer
especially in those comments right there
where he's basically saying that he has
zero faith in his fellow senators
it was their prerogative in their
assessment during that vote to determine
whether they needed
additional evidence to vote and to move
on those articles
of impeachment the votes said enough so
why all of a sudden when it suits
them first it's a political process and
then all of a sudden oh no no it's a
trial
that we see mirrored in actual courts
and therefore witnesses are a must but
there was zero discussion of evidence
i think the gop has extended a generous
amount of patience but it's not infinite
and so to your point about
just around the corner and just around
the corner and what about this at one
point is it going to end
the statement we just saw right there in
the vote it ends now
well the state of the union i don't
think they're gonna they'll figure out a
way i i they shouldn't delay the state
of the union
everybody wants the president to be oh i
shouldn't say everybody i'm making my
state of the union queso
oh wow yes if i if i can't have my case
this queso on the state of the union
i don't know what i'm going to do you
know what this story is about dana i'm
going to do like a like a lifetime thing
it's about the power of the house
the power of the president but most
important
the power of the media to shape a
narrative to suit their needs
that's what this is about you know what
this is like i remember after mueller
the president said he had been totally
exonerated
of course mueller said no such thing how
did that mueller thing work out you know
what
one no what i'm saying is the president
comes out and he just
talked about setting the way america but
mueller was a disaster for yourself it's
the guy with the bully pulpit and you
can be sure that's what trump is going
to say
even though that's not the case no but
mueller was a disaster for your side
every year the democrats
and then couldn't defend his own work
during a hearing
now you keep saying that trump is
destroying all these institutions i
would argue
that the left is destroying themselves
if you look at the fbi
the fbi agents peter strzok james comey
they destroyed that institution oh yeah
the media they have destroyed themselves
because no one believes the thing they
say anymore
because they lie the supreme court after
kavanaugh
you say that now institution has been
compromised no
that was another lie by people like
dianne feinstein and michael avenatti
and finally
now that the senate has constitutionally
on the verge of acquitting the president
you're saying now the senate as an
institution has been destroyed all right
all of that is not true let me just say
i think you owe all of those
institutions an apology no because
they're being damaged and i hate to see
it because i love america and i'm going
to tell you something the division
is evident in the fact that as we sit
here today dana was talking about the
numbers haven't moved
the numbers haven't moved from this
about half it is half the american
people think this guy should be out of
office
well they'll have an opportunity to vote
you know what'll heal people
you know what'll heal people do you know
that tomorrow night jesse
has a live show at eight o'clock yeah
and emily
is on the great gutfeld show tomorrow
night
and also juan and i will be here from 12
to 2 sunday for us
there's so many plugs it's like greg's
hair